allez on rappelle le principe les chéris
du sud chute j'ai des cartes ici on va
prendre chacun une carte et vous allez
devoir subir le gage en silence c'est
vous qui faisait cette émission sur w9
on adoré alors c'est très simple on a
tous déjà des cartes ici
regardez il ya du baby-sitting de
partout partout partout partout partout
partout est à temps partout partout
partout partout sauf il ya celle là et
vous alors attention je vais les
mélanges et je vais mélanger et y en a
trop déjà je mourrai exactement on est 1
2 3 4 5 6 on rajoute je suis courbet la
bombe à bien vos yeux d'enfant qu'il
soit la mesure un sachet mon sujet ça
fait super plaisir à 7 et un bénin du
coup c'est que là alors par contre il ya
un truc qui c'est important c'est cote
bref on a tous la carte on compte
jusqu'à 3 avant la retourne exactement
là on voit là on danse on joue pour
l'agent la lap dance brésilienne c'est
facile le perdant aura droit à une
lapdance très chaude sur une chaîne par
notre sur une chaise d'ailleurs par
notre charmeuse dans ce mondial ricardo
qui la saga qui lasse macra à la fin
qu'il a c'est quoi oulala
attention à deux balles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle horreur
on s'entoure gens tous les trucs
non
[Musique]
capcom à nola le perdant se veut rabbani
jaune et le visage d'une substance
collante
puis ce 33 la tête dans un sou de
compétition c'est le masque de carnaval
fait un carton à angoulême lundi n'ayant
pu moi aussi j'ai des dîners moi aussi
j'ai ma vie c'est sûr c'est parti alors
attention oui on mélange est allé non
pas sur vous mettez vous mettez votre
matos et j'ai la mienne j'ai l'âme et un
regard vous avez vu non attention à 2,3
à gratin
[Applaudissements]
le fond à la halle haas et or il a dans
ton manteau bleu menthe ou du champion
menton du champion la barre à l'arrivée
et le nez tu senti si on regarde est le
nez le nez le nez de recul et qu'on se
le dise tenir à cette année dans sa
valise tu vas tu fais comme ça attention
[Musique]
j'avais un peu mal tu vas vers le bol
parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
celui qui a la tête de mort devra faire
le mojito xxl pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent pour l'instant on a fait deux
fois ce jeu la fois notre ami camille
combal
je suis noir voilà et n'était pas bien
là le perdant se placera dans cette
baignoire et des autres on lui verser
tous les ingrédients du mojito rate à
dire beaucoup de glace 1 seulement un
saut de sucre de canne de l'autre et
fraîche et ensuite on lui donnera une
grosse panne et il pourra boire mais
sympa si très simple c'est sympa
attention un deux trois
[Applaudissements]
madame envoyé gentiment le dise
ces mauviettes si si les mots ou bien
vous aider nous des essais
y'a pas les yeux mouillés
maintenant qu'on est allé froide alors
on va mettre m'étais d'abord en ligne
allez sur les yeux on va mettre
maintenant je bosse comme ça où on va
mettre d'abord par la glace attention
maintenant le sucre de canon
[Applaudissements]
alessio et enfin on va mettre la glace
des glaciers de la bête
allez les invités à les lacets mathieu
de l'instruction a les yeux pas les ssii
leçon
[Musique]
on mélange est la pire des cas mais il
va boire il veut voir un petit peu
camille avec plaisir avec le jeu de
chaussettes allait alléger mon cas mais
dites-nous si c'est bon c'est non alors
c'est pas si mal je suis il prend en
compte celle qui n'est pas dégueu mais
bon alors est ce que vous voulez voir
les images de la pub à l'école est sûre
vous avez triché mais où on regarde les
images et vous me direz si vous
considérez que ce que j'ai fait c'est
tricher regarde vous me direz peut-être
vous n'avez pas considérer que c'est
tricher
j'ai une idée je tends vers une idée
vous considérerez également chez vous
sur twitter astag triche
regardez
g
[Musique]
enora change et affiche voilà brasse les
images parlent d'elles mêmes
personne n'a triché